At this point you should have most
of the server side, Firebase, and
Google stuff set up.
So let's go back to our Android app and
talk about what we need to do to
get that ready for Google login.
The big picture goal is to get
an OAuth token from Google and
then hand that token over to Firebase.
And this is all going to
happen Android app side.
Once you've gotten your OAuth token,
the process is very similar to
logging in with email and password.
You call Auth with OAuth token, then
Firebase uses the OAuth token to get
data from Google, after which Firebase
creates for you that handy JWT, and
of course your AuthData object.
And then finally you get
your AuthData object so
that you can update your android UI.
Now getting an OAuth token from
Google requires a fair amount of
boilerplate code.
And I've linked to Google
authentication example, so
you can take a look through it.
Let's take a quick look at
what's going on in our app.
Okay, so
I'm in the LoginActivity class, and
if you scroll down you'll see that here,
prefaced by this large comment,
is all of the boilerplate code
that I took to get the token.
So really all this code is just
to get that OAuth token and
it's nothing too special but
you can read through it.
Now, I've left the interesting
part of connecting the OAuth token
to Firebase for you to do.
Now, there are more things that you need
to do with Google which are outlined in
the Firebase and Google Authentication
to be able to get that token.
These include adding some libraries to
Gradle, generating a config file, and
adding permissions to the manifest.
I'll provide you with
the links in the spec document
with how to set all of that up.
Once you've got the OAuth token, signing
into Google is almost exactly the same
as signing in with email and password.
Instead of an email and password,
though, you provide the provider name
which in this case is Google and
that special OAuth Token.
The result handler works
exactly the same though.
If the user is logged into Google and
give shopping list plus plus all the
correct permissions then onAuthenticator
will be called and you'll have that
handy dandy authData parameter.
You should do the same thing with
a user who logs in via Google
as a user who logs in with email and
password.
Your app should send them
to the main activity and
not take them back to the login
page if they click the back button.
Okay, let me send you the spec.